hablemos un poco del ciclo del agua
seguramente ya lo conoce
de hecho formamos parte del ciclo del
agua cada momento de nuestras vidas
aunque tal vez no nos demos cuenta
pero vamos a ver empecemos con la
evaporación podemos empezar con la
superficie del océano o en este río o en
este lago y en cualquier momento hay
agua evaporándose de la superficie
algunas de las moléculas de agua que se
encuentran en estado líquido tienen la
energía suficiente para escaparse y
pasan al estado gaseoso y al agua en
estado gaseoso la llamamos vapor vapor
entonces ese vapor de agua se eleva
junto con el aire que se calentó en la
superficie por el sol y ocurre en otras
interacciones complejas pero conforme se
eleva y conforme su temperatura total se
enfría ese vapor de agua se condensará
en pequeñas gotitas se condensará
alrededor de pequeñas partículas de
polvo y aire que incluso no podemos ver
con nuestros ojos y así se formarán las
nubes entonces estas son pequeñas
gotitas y después el agua regresa al
estado líquido todavía no son moléculas
de agua individuales pero puede
interactuar consigo misma y se condensa
alrededor de partículas microscópicas de
polvo para formar esas gotitas de agua y
miren si se encuentran lo
suficientemente frías también se pueden
formar pequeños cristales de hielo de
todo eso están hechas las nubes y
podemos ver que antes de eso se habla de
transporte
miren tenemos a las nubes
y por ejemplo si ahorita nos asomamos
por la ventana y observamos las nubes
podemos ver que se mueven con el aire
entonces con el aire se van moviendo
todas estas gotitas de agua y cuando
esas gotitas pesen lo suficiente se
precipitaran es decir se caerán ahora
puede que precipiten de regreso a donde
empezaron pueden regresar al océano o
también puede que caigan en una montaña
y en este caso como el aire es muy frío
si tenemos las condiciones adecuadas la
precipitación podría ser nieve y
mantenerse como nieve o hielo pero en
algún momento una parte de eso se
calentará así que un poco de esta nieve
se derretirá y entonces ocurre el
escurrimiento de deshielo que es lo que
vemos aquí ahora si la lluvia cae en
esta área supongamos que aquí no hace
suficiente frío como para que el agua se
convierta en nieve estamos hablando de
lluvia
bueno la mayoría de esa agua se filtrara
por la tierra entonces la mayor parte se
va hacia abajo ok y aquí podemos ver
estos ríos y lagos y podemos decir oh
hay mucha agua aquí pero resulta que
debajo de la tierra hay todavía más agua
bueno y obviamente en el océano entonces
tenemos toda esta agua que forman los
mantos acuíferos subterráneos pero un
poco de eso también termina en estos
lagos y los lagos existen en lugares
donde el suelo ya sea que esté saturado
de agua o que se encuentra en el tipo de
rocas adecuadas para que el agua no se
filtre y de forma similar los ríos se
forman por el deshielo el escurrimiento
de deshielo puede formar ríos y
generalmente si ven un arroyo o un río
cerca de su casa especialmente cuando
llueve es una buena señal de que las
aguas subterráneas están saturadas
entonces el agua corre por el río
así que en general ese es el ciclo del
agua
primero se evapora y después se condensa
en las nubes hasta que en algún momento
se precipita una y otra vez y claro
también intervienen otras cosas como por
ejemplo tenemos a las plantas y las
plantas absorben un poco de agua del
subsuelo tan lejos como llegan sus
raíces y usarán esa agua para
transportar los nutrientes desde el
suelo hasta sus hojas y también usan el
agua como parte del proceso de
fotosíntesis proceso que hemos estudiado
en otros vídeos y después mucha de esa
agua se transpira esta es la
transpiración que simplemente es la
evaporación del agua en las hojas
y por acá tenemos la palabra sublimación
que es el cambio de estado de agua
sólida hielo a gas es decir vapor de
agua esto sucede en situaciones en las
que hace mucho frío el ambiente está muy
muy seco y que además generalmente
existe una presión baja entonces en
lugar de pasar al estado líquido las
moléculas de agua se transforman
directamente en vapor de agua y bueno
claro nosotros también formamos parte
del ciclo pero de qué forma bueno
nosotros ingerimos un poco de esta agua
dulce y la mayor parte de nuestro cuerpo
es agua las células de nuestro cuerpo
contienen 70% de agua y para todo lo que
estudiamos en biología el agua es un
medio muy importante para que todas las
cosas puedan ocurrir entonces nosotros
usamos esa agua y después la sacamos de
nuestro cuerpo y así una y otra vez es
como formamos parte
este ciclo ahora algo que me parece muy
interesante como organismos que
dependemos del agua dulce bueno cuando
decimos agua dulce estamos hablando de
agua sin sal diferente del agua salada
nosotros realmente necesitamos el agua
dulce que hay en este lago o en este río
e incluso podemos cavar pozos para
obtener el agua de los acuíferos pero
resulta que sólo una pequeña parte de
toda el agua en el mundo es agua dulce
miren quiero enseñarles esto yo siempre
lo supe pero no me había dado cuenta de
que tan pequeña es la proporción de agua
dulce del planeta vamos a ver de toda el
agua que existe en nuestro planeta el
97.5 por ciento es agua salada la mayor
parte se encuentra en los océanos pero
solamente el 2.5 por ciento es agua
dulce y de ese 2.5 por ciento muy poco
se encuentra en lo que normalmente
asociamos con él
dulce es decir los ríos y los lagos
cuando pienso en agua dulce me imagino
un río o un lago agua que generalmente
podemos beber pero la mayor parte del
agua dulce en realidad se encuentre en
los glaciares y en las capas de nieve
permanentes entonces esto es hielo o
nieve y no se está derritiendo pero eso
nos hace pensar en qué pasaría si todo
esto se derritiera y bueno también
tenemos agua subterránea a la que
podemos tener acceso por eso las
personas cavan pozos y esta agua se
refiere a la humedad del suelo agua
pantanosa y permafrost es decir capas
congeladas pero muy poca agua dulce se
encuentra en ríos y lagos lo que
personalmente me parece fascinante no
era obvio para mí hasta que vi este
gráfico ahora otra cosa interesante
sobre esto es conocer en promedio cuánto
tiempo pueden permanecer las moléculas
de agua en las diferentes partes del
ciclo entonces si regrese
aquí imaginen que una molécula de agua
puede permanecer por mucho tiempo en el
océano claro dependiendo de las
corrientes del océano y de la
temperatura pero podemos imaginar que
permanece en estado líquido en el océano
por mucho tiempo y tal vez pasa un corto
periodo de tiempo en una nube y de hecho
eso es algo que ya han estudiado lo cual
me parece impresionante me gustaría
mucho saber cómo es que obtuvieron estos
datos estos datos corresponden al tiempo
de residencia promedio para las
moléculas de agua y aquí podemos ver que
el agua puede permanecer en los
glaciares y permafrost por mucho tiempo
miren hasta 10.000 años bueno todo esto
es una aproximación y puede permanecer
como agua subterránea donde sea desde
dos semanas hasta diez mil años
dependiendo de qué tan aislada se
encuentra esa agua subterránea
también puede permanecer en los océanos
y mares como agua salada hasta por 4000
años y podemos seguir analizando todo
esto hasta llegar a los seres vivos en
los que pueden permanecer hasta una
semana en promedio y en la atmósfera es
decir en forma de vapor de agua
convirtiéndose en nube y después
precipitándose ocurre en promedio en una
semana y media todos estos son promedios
no significan que cada molécula de agua
permanecerá exactamente una semana y
media en la atmósfera pero es una forma
muy interesante de verlo y nos da una
mejor noción de dónde se encuentra toda
el agua y cómo funciona el ciclo del
agua